- I mean, look at this.
- They're so cute.
- This is good TV.
- Who cares what I'm
talking about right now
because look at this.
(audience cheers)
- I am a huge puppy fan,
cuz puppies are better than humans.
I love cats, I'm allergic.
- Three.
- Up.
- Oh!
- In that direction-
- Hi, buddy.
- Oh, is he, oh, okay, I
thought he was in my sleeve.
I was like, "Oh bro, we got an issue."
Did you hear Noel?
(sheep bleats)
(bell rings)
(upbeat music)
- I was at the house in Oklahoma,
and I was just, I was there by myself,
and I just grilled something on the grill.
And I got it out.
I was letting it cool off
and I went back to get it
and there's a damn opossum over there.
Look!
Eating my, I actually grilled some fish.
- Oh my God.
- Hold up, here together, hurry up.
All right, Paul.
Right, here you go.
Look at this, look at this.
Oh wow.
Yum, yum.
Watch this, here we go, ready?
Where'd it go?
What?
(gasps)
- Wait, where did it go?
- And now he gets mad.
- Not in my face.
- Real mad.
- So besides being adorable,
what kind of things can
mini horses do to comfort?
- [Horse Handler] Well, as you can see-
- [Kelly] Look at that!
(audiences laughs)
- Do I know how to do it?
- [Pig Handler] You clearly
have done this with babies?
- [Kelly] Like I'm trying-
- [Pig Handler] Where you
dangle the bottle over them.
- [Kelly] I'm trying.
- Oh, you can't eat the flowers.
Look at Dante.
- [Puppy Handler] No, no!
- Of course I pick the psycho.
I love it.
I don't know if she's peed on me,
but I'm totally cool with it either way.
So you just lay here, lovely.
All right.
- Coming at you.
- Don't you walk the front of that table.
- I feel like I walk
like that after drinking.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh my God, it's on the back.
I'm a mom, I'm a mom.
You gotta get it, you gotta get it.
I love my job.